je suis avec mes bronches avec ma team
ici elle a pris la tâche demandée de
switcher tout de suite là on a les
soeurs chacun dans votre guirlandes au
vermouth et le fps créé par blizzard
c'est un jeu où des équipes de six
joueurs s'affrontent sur différents
modes de jeu
il ya au total 23 personnages qui
viennent chacun d'un pays différent et
surtout d'une époque différente de la
vraie rivalité il y en a qui sait bien
qu'ils s'aiment pas donc c'est drôle m6
il ya vraiment un truc à faire avec ce
délire là et je me suis dit hé bah on va
les faire se clasher et du mois avec
avec son antenne du cateau bien sa jambe
c'est une barre de pole dance pour mimie
mathy ou quoi je garde justement
une dizaine à ma mère aimait tout elle a
fait tuer 600 foyers parisiens
[Musique]
malaise
bref tu vois c'est parti on est parti
pour le make up de chakan moi je suis un
petit peu le parent et de la banque deux
heures de make up et on se retrouve tous
dans deux heures avec une tronche déjà
rend différente france
[Musique]
je suis très ravi de ce tournage là il
reste il va devenir squeeze c'est moi
c'est battent les menus adaptés sur la
tête
look c'est pas facile d'être un ange
j'aime les trucs l'azerbaïdjan qui ne
perd pas la spirale
et du coup ça lui ça mc rae et je vais
tourner mais ça
et à 13 heures là bas je dirais je me
crois trop dans mon rôle gérant
l'ensemble sur un vin rouge que
rencontrent les poteaux d'acier tout
changer on était comme des gamins à
l'idée de ressembler aux persos de rock
mais mais je vais pas vous mentir ça a
quand même un peu démystifier les persos
le fait de mettre ses costumes l'a dans
le sang soit en fait il ya des
contraintes de malades dont on n'avait
même pas idée
la montée patients perso qui galèrent le
plus au monde
version d'abus
on a découvert son secret
ce bastion il ya un [ __ ] du matin et
qui sait où dans le clip très sûr pour
un moment très très vite
ok c'est très stylé mais dans la vraie
vie ça l'est un peu moins mais tout ça
dans le clip rend très bien donc on peut
vraiment remercier les gars aux effets
spéciaux parce qu'ils ont rendu le truc
très épique
mon personnage ses anges et je suis
censé soigner les gens du coup par
exemple si vous avez un maux de gorge et
bunge à une pastille drilles a distribué
comme ça hop et une âme à la corde raide
les plus sexy mais casse toi tais toi
c'est la première fois je crois que
blizzard communique avec des youtuber
dans le pipe on n'a pas l'impression
mais à aucun moment ils sont tous
ensemble c'est que à chaque fois des
rustines de alors attends on va tourner
ciprian telle heure à telle heure on va
tourner meet a tall rappelle moi
j'aimerais qu'on salue le taf de
sélections de jeune fille qui ont fait
un cosplay magnifique avec des trucs de
l'aide s'est fait tout ça avec des
papiers recyclés du commerce équitable
quel on allait elle-même chercher un peu
distant c'est quand même un jeune dj
killer fallait tuer un interphone qu'un
peu
de grenoble 1 38 isère eh ben ils ont
trouvé moi est sûr que ça ça marche
plutôt bien je pense que t'en penses
situé quai
notre pari
la tournée les leclerc s'il vous plaît
de faire de notre région les conforama a
pas de problème peut venir chez vous
chantez l'agencé bonjour là bonjour tu
te prends pour un d'elton avec tes
bottes et onze personnes mais laisse moi
te rappeler que ton nom
ce n'est personne moi la merci demain il
fera 13 me de dans l'air et je voulais
sur un son excellent c'est le nouveau
tube qui vient de sortir ses 15 8 ans ne
participe pas que pitbull son père
ils ont tout pour une rage une foule et
valentin maury ont fait un travail
absolument génial et merci à eux parce
qu'à la base il faut savoir que moi
j'avais écrit moi-même je trop quatre
couples et du truc vu que je suis
extrêmement mauvais en musique etc en
plus toutes les semaines je dois sortir
une vidéo sur ma chaîne bassam laissé
très peu de temps pour faire quelque
chose que je maîtrise très peu il faut
savoir que cette chanson a été écrit
avec des chaussons et en buvant du thé
comme bon nombre de rappeurs des tisanes
terminé sur un petit colon n'a quand
même passé un temps fou à écrire ce
cette chanson il faut être honnête pour
chaque perso on explorait le champ
lexical par exemple du feu pour chacal
de la glace pour mail et on cherchait
des vannes en vrac et on avait gardé
qu'un tiers on va dire pour chacun
l'initié bas parce qu'on parle
d'histoire en fait
enfin surtout voilà d'après jeté sur un
tournage avec autant d'autres copains
youtuber doit plus dire oh la la lucas
qui sort de ces jeux vidéo et qui veut
faire un clip tard floch pas très chaud
en fin de tournage enfin un jour avec
ces gens là c'est compliqué de ton avec
des gens immatures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en huit ans je suis hyper content du
résultat je suis hyper content de
tournage de la chanson où les gens qui
ont créé ce ont été extradés fait
spéciale ils ont été trahis tout le
monde a donné du sien de et sa bonne
volonté et à apporter son petit grain au
truc
donc merci à tous les poteaux qui ont
rejoint le projet et puis merci à vous
d'avoir regardé la vidéo
j'espère que ce gros gros projets vous a
plu et puis qui sait on aura peut-être
doute comme ça à l'avenir on sait pas a
très vite au revoir très sérieux comme
ça à bientôt
merci
[Musique]